hello and welcome everyone to yet
another tech enthusiastic video from
simply learn today we will be learning
how to install Sam server and Windows
operating system but they follow begin
please be kind enough to get subscribed
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
icon so that you can see updated about
the trending technologies in the current
IT industry also if you're looking for
an online training and certification
program on the latest technologies like
DNA science machine learning and
artificial intelligence or to master the
cutting-edge programming languages like
Java Python c-sharp etc then please
visit the simply learn official website
to enroll master and get certified now
without much ado let us dive into our
session
so the agenda for today's session is
what exactly is Zam where we'll have a
briefing about the Sam software followed
by that vision goes to the procedure for
installing Sam in Windows
so I hope I made myself clear with the
agenda now let's quickly begin with our
first topic what exactly is Sam well Sam
is a one-stop open source cross-platform
solution for multiple needs in general
it is considered as a bundle of software
utilities that include an Apache server
my sequel database support for PHP and
support for pull this simple and
lightweight solution works on Windows
Linux and Mac hence the cross-platform
part now that we have a quick briefing
about zamp let us get started with the
installation procedure
so installing zamp is really simple all
you need to do is just Google and
download samp and you will see the first
link and just click onto it which will
redirect you into the Apache web site
here you can see multiple varieties of
samp the first one is for windows second
is for linux and the third one is from
mac now we will select the windows
version so here we have the 7.2 version
seven point three and seven point four
so I would suggest you to go with the
latest version that is a seven point
four you just need to click on the
download button and there you go
you can see on the bottom left corner
that your software is getting downloaded
now this might take a while so I have
downloaded it on my local system
previously so let's get back to that and
start our installation for seizure just
a save time so I might want to cancel
this so let's get back to the download
section and there you go you can see the
samp software which is downloaded here
so all you need to do is just run it
to just provide the permission yes
ignore this warning and just select okay
you can start the visit by clicking next
so here you can see multiple options for
serve our programming languages etc so
you have the varieties of server such as
Apache my sequel FileZilla etc Tomcat
you never know which one you might need
in the future so I would suggest you to
just select all and same goes for the
programming languages just select next
so now you can see the next dialog box
where you're asked to select the quiche
for your software so it would be better
if you select the default location that
is c-drive
to select next and here you asked to
select the different languages for your
control panel so let us select English
English is a default option here now
let's click Next again and next and now
your software is ready to get installed
don't worry about this new web page
which is popped up in your screen now
let's get back to a set of file
now let's just select next to start with
the installation and there you go you
can see that zamp is getting installed
into your local system now this might
take up a little while all you need to
do is just wait
anytime now the installation will be
finished so there you go the
installation is completely finished now
you can just click on the finish button
and the process will be finished
and there you go you can see your samp
control panel on your screen let's
maximize this for a better view
yeah that's good now you can see the
modules on your control panel which are
the Apache server my sequel database
FileZilla server Mercury server Tomcat
server you can start any one of these
let's get started with Apache first to
start that all you need to do is just
select the start button
and you can see the Apache has just got
started and you can see the first one
was attempting the Apache app to be get
started and then you can see the Apache
app state is changed to running now you
can see the process IDs of Apache server
as well as the port number which is 80
now you have an option of configuring
your port numbers because what if in
future you may need to start Tomcat and
Apache server parallely but in different
port numbers so to make sure that they
don't interfere with each other
you can configure them on different port
numbers to do so all you need to do is
just open conflict
and inside contract choose the first
option that is Apache HTTP deacons
just scroll to the bottom and now you
can see the port number here so just let
us change it to 3000
similarly here
and now select the file option and save
it
now let's try to restart our batch a
server stoppin and then again restart it
and there you go you can see the change
of the port number to 3000 and the
process IDs which are 96 to zero and 90
to succeed so this is how you install
Zam server and this is a complete
procedure to install Sam server into
your Windows operating system and with
this we have come to an end of this
session I hope this was resourceful if
you have any queries regarding this
session then please feel free to write
them down in the comment section below
also don't forget to get subscribe to
the simply learn youtube channel and hit
the bell I can to stay connected to us
and get important updates based on the
current ID this is Ravi signing off
thank you until next time
[Music]
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Dinard up and get certified click
here